dans la vidéo d'aujourd'hui on va
essayer de refaire ensemble un calcul
historique qui a été fait la première
fois par Einstein en 1915 alors qu'il
était en train de finir l'élaboration de
sa théorie de la relativité générale et
ce calcul il est assez assez historique
puisque c'est la première preuve
expérimentale de sa théorie c'est le
calcul de l'avance du périéide mercure
alors le problème du périéide mercure
c'est le suivant dans le système solaire
on a le soleil qui est au centre et puis
les planètes tournent autour du Soleil
et en particulier la planète Mercure
tourne autour du soleil sous la forme
d'une ellipse alors ici j'exagère
l'ellipse en réalité c'est presque un
cercle mais toutes les planètes suivent
des orbites comme ça en forme d'ellipse
c'est ce qu'on appelle les orbites de
Kepler et la forme de cette ellipse est
déterminé par la loi de Newton le
problème c'est que dans le système
solaire les planètes ne sont pas seules
autour du soleil il y a d'autres
planètes on a Vénus la Terre Mars et
cetera et toutes ces planètes vont
exercer des petites forces d'attraction
sur la planète
Mercure de sorte à la faire dévier
légèrement de sa trajectoire périodique
autour du soleil alors bien sûr la force
d'attraction qui reste majoritaire c'est
celle du soleil mais toutes ces petites
forces vont légèrement dévier l'ellipse
si bien qu'après une
orbite Mercure se trouve sur une ellipse
qui est légèrement décalée et donc le
point ici où mercure passe le plus près
du soleil c'est ce qu'on appelle le
périéli et bien il s'est décalé et à
l'orbite suivante mercure suit une
ellipse légèrement décalée avec un
périéie légèrement en avance alors
encore une fois ici c'est très exagéré
le décalage de l'ellipse en réalité il
est vraiment minime et s'effectue au
cours de siècles et de siècles et en
fait la théorie de Newton permet de
calculer cette avance du Périé de
mercure en prenant en compte
l'attraction gravitationnelle des autres
planètes dans le Système solaire le
problème c'est qu'on obtient une valeur
qui est presque identique à ce qu'on
observe mais légèrement supérieur on
observe une anomalie il y a 43 secondes
d'arc par siècle de différence avec
l'observation et qui visiblement n'est
pas dû à la présence d'autres planètes
donc il y a une avance du périéide
mercure qui est d à la force de gravité
elle-même alors une seconde d'arc c'est
un 36è de degré en angle par analogie
entre les heures et les secondes et donc
vous voyez que c'est vraiment un angle
minuscule 43 3600 cè de degrés par
siècle donc c'est vraiment quelque chose
d'assez difficile à dceler et à l'époque
beaucoup de chercheurs se disent que
cette différence n'est pas forcément
très importante mais en fait elle va
constituer la première preuve
expérimentale de la relativité générale
qui permet justement de trouver cette
valeur exacte de 43 secondes d'arc alors
dans cette vidéo on va pas s'intéresser
au calcul avec les autres planètes c'est
un calcul qui est assez fastidieux donc
sil va nous intéresser c'est de
considérer un système solaire avec
uniquement le soleil et Mercure et on va
voir que dans ce système-là avec la
relativité générale l'orbite préesse
quand même même s'il n'y a pas d'autres
planète le périéis se décale quand même
de 43 secondes d'arc par siècle qui est
la différence prédite par la relativité
bon alors c'est parti pour commencer on
va déterminer la géométrie de
l'espace-temps dans laquelle on veut
travailler euh la géométrie de
l'espace-temps va considérer que la
masse de mercure est très inférieure à
celle du soleil ce qui est effectivement
le cas et que le soleil est à peu près
sphérique et statique qui n'est pas trop
au cours du temps par rapport à la
vitesse de la lumière et ça ça nous
permet d'utiliser la métrique de
schwarzield qui est la métrique standard
en relativité général pour étudier un
corps sphérique et statique donc la
métrique de Schield s'écrit de la façon
suivante DS car est ég à C car DT car
facteur de 1- RS sur
R Dr car sur 1- RS sur
R r car d Phi car
alors là je vais vous expliquer un peu
ce que c'est si vous n'avez pas
l'habitude déjà on se place dans le plan
orbital de la planète donc on néglige
une troisième dimension donc on a que
deux dimensions d'espace les deux
dimensions d'espace ça va être nos deux
coordonnées R et Phi alors r C'est la
coordonnée radiale mesurée depuis le
centre du Soleil donc en fait c'est une
sorte d'altitude par rapport au centre
du Soleil Phi c'est un angle mesuré par
rapport à un axe quelconque donc c'est
l'angle que forme la planète Mercure par
rapport à un axe et puis t c'est la
position temporelle de la planète
lorsqu'on mesure le temps sur l'horloge
d'un observateur très lointain
puisque'en relativité le temps est
relatif et donc en particulier la
planète Mercure va porter son propre
temps le temps propre de mercure qu'on
va noter petit Tau et donc à cause des
effets de dilatation du temps il faut
prendre en compte la coordonnée
temporelle petit t comme s'il s'agissait
d'une troisième dimension c'est la
dimension du temps
alors ces petits d devant les
coordonnées DT D r d Phi ça indique
simplement qu'on s'intéresse à des
petites différences de coordonnées donc
on imagine qu'on a deux événements dans
l'espace-temps qui sont séparés dans
l'espace et dans le temps donc ils ont
pas les mêmes coordonnées donc imaginons
par exemple que cette séparation c'est
suivant l'altitude et puis cette
séparation c'est suivant le temps et
bien cette métrique ds² nous permet de
mesurer cette distance là de
l'hypoténuse entre guillemets donc c'est
la distance qui sépare dans
l'espace-temp les deux points alors
c'est une distance abstraite et en fait
cette distance c'est ça qu'on appelle le
temps propre qu'on va noter DTO avec un
facteur C pour convertir c'est la
vitesse de la lumière ce petit C il nous
permet de convertir du temps en unité de
longueur et puis enfin ce RS qui
intervient ici c'est ce qu'on appelle le
rayon de Schwarz shield il s'écrit comme
ça Rs é= 2 GM sur c² où g c'est la
constante de gravité de Newton et puis M
c'est la masse du Soleil qui attire
mercure et en particulier dans le cas du
soleil ce rayon de SH shield il vaut
environ 3 km donc il est vraiment tout
petit par rapport aux distances
astronomique qui sépare les deux
astres bon alors à partir de cette
métrique on aimerait déterminer le
mouvement de mercure au cours du temps
et là ce qui nous arrange c'est que la
métrique elle ne dépend que d'une seule
coordonnée vous voyez qu'on a seulement
la coordonnée r l'altitude qui
intervient dans tous ces termes la
coordonnée t n'intervient pas on a
seulement sa variation t mais on n pas t
lui-même qui intervient et la coordonnée
Phi n'intervient pas non plus et ça
c'est assez logique la gravité autour
d'un corps statique et sphérique ne
dépend pas du temps elle n'évolue pas au
cours du temps et puis elle ne dépend
pas de l'angle la gravité est la même
dans toutes les directions par contre
elle dépend de l'altitude la gravité
n'est pas la même en fonction de la
distance au Soleil et donc on a une
métrique qui est symétrique qui est
invariante par rapport à deux
coordonnées T et phi et ça grâce au
théorème de notire on sait que ça va
nous donner des grandeurs qui se
conservent au cours de la trajectoire et
ces grandeurs en fait elles vont être
données par la dérivée de tout ça par
rapport aux intervalles de coordonnées
DT et d Phi puisque c'est ces deux
coordonnées là T et Phi qui ne font pas
changer la maétrique donc la première
grandeur c'est lorsqu'on prend la
dérivée de tout ça par rapport à DT donc
ces deux term ne dépendent pas de DT on
va obtenir seulement une dérivée de ceci
dt² lorsqu'on le dérive par rapport à DT
ça donne 2 DT et donc on va obtenir
quelque chose de la forme 2 c² DT 1- rs/
R et pour avoir une grandeur qui n'est
pas infinitésimale on va diviser par DTO
on va avoir DT sur des tau c'est-à-dire
le rythme auquel évolue la coordonnée t
par rapport au temps propre de la
planète et ça on va le Notter t
point c'est l'une des composantes de la
vitesse spaciottemporelle de la planète
Mercure alors en particulier on peut
diviser par 2 et puis on peut diviser
par c² puisque ce sont des constantes et
donc ce qui nous intéresse c'est
vraiment les choses qui peuvent varier
et le théorème de noteur nous dit que
cette grandeur e qu'on appelle plus
communément l'énergie elle est conservé
et donc ensuite on a une deuxième
grandeur conservée qu'on va noter grand
H qui elle est la dérivée de tout ça par
rapport à défi donc on a uniquement ce
terme qui intervient défi carré
lorsqu'on le dérive ça va donner deux
défis et donc on va obtenir - 2 r² D phi
et puis encore une fois on peut diviser
par - 2 puisque c'est une constante et
on divise par détau pour obtenir ici Phi
point c'est-à-dire la vitesse angulaire
de la planète autour du
Soleil cette deuxième grandeur conservée
c'est ce qu'on appelle le moment
cinétique donc on peut réinjecter ces
expressions là dans la métrique si on
divise toute la métrique par D tau carré
donc on obtient à la place de DT carré
t Point Carré Dr car on obtient r Point
Carré et puis d Phi Carr on obtient Phi
Point
Carré et on avait vu que ds car c'était
directement C DTO au carré donc
lorsqu'on divise par DTO carré ça va
donner simplement C car et ça c'est ce
qu'on entend parfois lorsqu'on dit que
tous les objets dans l'espace-temps se
déplacent à la vitesse de la lumière
c'est le fait que ici c'est la vitesse
de la lumière qui est la norme de la
vitesse spaciot-temporelle lorsqu'on
prend en compte les trois coordonnées
d'espace et de temps de notre
planète donc si on réinjecte ici alors
on va résoudre pour les valeurs de t
point et pH point t point du coup c'est
e sur 1- rs/
R et puis Phi point c'est h sur
R2 alors réinjectons ces deux
expressions je vais réécrire la maîtrice
un peu en dessous c² é= C car t car donc
c² e car sur 1- rs/ r au carré ça c'est
t point Carr facteur de 1- RS sur R donc
ça m'annule un des deux facteurs qui est
en
bas moin r car sur 1- rs/ r mais là je
peux le factoriser directement en haut
puisque c'est le même
dénominateur et moin r car pH car
c'est-à-dire Mo r²
h² sur R4 et là le r Carr en haut vient
s'annuler avec 2 des puissances de r en
bas et donc j'ai du H car sur
R2 et là ce qui est très intéressant
avec cette expression c'est qu'on a
désormais la valeur de r Point Carré
donc la variation d'altitude au cours du
temps par rapport à uniquement des
constantes et des variables du problème
en particulier l'altitude r donc là on a
une équation différentielle et on
pourrait essayer de résoudre cette
équation pour trouver la fonction R de
taux c'est-à-dire l'altitude au cours du
temps de la planète le problème c'est
que cette expression elle est très
difficile à trouver mais par contre on
peut faire une petite manipulation pour
trouver quelque chose qui nous intéresse
davantage en particulier nous le temps
ne nous intéresse pas vraiment ce qui
nous intéresse c'est plutôt la forme de
l'orbite c'est-à-dire en fait l'altitude
de la planète en fonction de
l'angle qu'elle trace autour du sol
donc en fait ce qu'il nous faut c'est
plutôt la fonction R de Phi puisque
lorsqu'on aura la fonction d'altitude r
en fonction de l'angle et bien on saura
quelle est la forme de l'orbite donc on
va noter tout de suite que R est une
fonction de Phi qui dépend lui-même de
taux du temps propre et on va noter r
prime la dérivée de la fonction r par
rapport à Phi donc par rapport à l'angle
en fait on a la dérivée d'une fonction
composée qui nous dit que si on dérive r
par rapport au temps propre r point ça
va donner la dérivée de r par rapport à
Phi r prime fois la dérivée de Phi par
rapport au temps propre et ça on peut le
réinjecter ici donc r Point Carré ça va
devenir r Prim
car facteur de Phi Point Carré mais Phi
point on sait que c'est h sur R2 donc
facteur de H2 sur
R4 alors ici pour faire un peu de ménage
je vais multiplier des deux côtés par 1-
rs/
R et ça me permet de supprimer le
dénominateur alors maintenant on voit
qu'on a une expression qui n'est
toujours pas très simple mais une astuce
euh alors pour le coup qu'il faut
connaître qui est pas forcément évidente
au premier coup d'œil mais qu'on a déjà
utilisé dans la vidéo sur les lois de
Kepler c'est la même astuce que
lorsqu'on dérive la forme d'une orbite
avec la théorie de Newton ça va être de
poser une nouvelle variable U qui est
l'inverse de l'altitude r 1/ r
symétriquement r c'est l'inverse de U
alors pourquoi ça nous arrange ben on va
le voir après en fait ça va permettre de
simplifier cette équation
différentielle maintenant il faut
exprimer r prime en fonction de U alors
r prime c'est la dérivée donc de 1/ U
puisque r c'est 1/ u donc la dérivée de
1/ U ça va être 1/ u car FO la dérivée
de U u Prim faisons le remplacement r
prime car ça devient 1 sur u 4 facteur
de U prime car alors c'est pas très
propre ici je vais le réécrire en
dessous on a du U Prim car h car sur U4
R4 et ce qui est pratique ici c'est que
vous voyez que U et R u c'est 1/ r donc
les deux vont s'annuler U4 x R4 ça donne
1 et c'est ça qui est vraiment très
pratique dans ce changement de
variable je réécris ça
ici et pour finir finir on voit qu'on a
ce h² ici qui intervient souvent donc on
va diviser par h² des deux
côtés alors maintenant notre équation
elle mélange du U prime et du 1/ R donc
on va remplacer aussi 1/ r par
U et là on a presque terminé ce qu'on va
vouloir faire c'est s'arranger pour
éliminer certaines de ces constantes
vous voyez que ça par exemple c'est une
constante ça ce 1 x c² sur H2 c'est
aussi une constante donc pour éliminer
ces constantes et avoir quelque chose
qui est plus simple à résoudre on va
dériver toute cette équation puisque la
dérivée d'une constante ça donne 0 on va
dériver en particulier par rapport à
l'angle Phi donc ces dérivées là noté
avec des primes donc ici la dérivée de
ça bien le premier terme s'annule c'est
un terme constant le deuxième j'ai moin
RS u donc la dérivée c'est - RS u prime
donc j'obtiens RS u prime facteur de c²
sur H
Carr est égal à la dérivée de ça c'est
une constante donc ça s'annule moins la
dérivée de U prime Carr donc c'est - 2 U
prime FO la dérivée de U Prim c'est u
Prim prime ça c'est la dérivée seconde
de la variable U qui est 1/ r par
rapport à l'angle Phi moins la dérivée
de tout ça alors je vais euh ici
développer le produit j'ai u² x 1 - RS u
donc ça donne u² + RS u³ donc la dérivée
de ce premier terme u² ça donne - 2 U u
prime et ce 2è terme u³ ça donne 3 RS u²
u
prime je remarque que u
prime est un facteur commun à tous ces
termes donc je peux diviser par U prime
des deux côtés on va diviser par - 2
pour obtenir un facteur 1 devant ce u
Prim prime donc quand je divise par - 2
ici j'ai 1 ici j'ai + U
là j'ai - 3
demi et puis à gauche j'ai RS sur 2 mais
on sait que RS je l'ai noté un peu plus
haut RS c'est 2 GM sur c² donc RS sur 2
c'est GM sur
c² et ce C car va s'annuler et donc on
obtient en fait une constante ici qui ne
dépend pas de la vitesse de la lumière
et cette constante ça veut dire qu'elle
n'est pas relativiste c'est constante
qui existe aussi dans le calcul
newtonien et là on a obtenu notre
première équation l'équation
fondamentale qui va nous permettre de
trouver la forme des orbites alors je
vais la réécrire en dessous pour que ce
soit un peu plus clair on a u Prim prime
+ u
32 de RS
u² est égal à une constante GM sur
h² cette équation si vous vous souvenez
de la vidéo sur les orbites de Kepler et
bien on l'avait déjà obtenu avec la
théorie de Newton mais sans ce terme ici
puisque ce terme dépend de rayon de
schwarzfield et donc c'est vraiment un
terme relativiste qui est très petit
puisque ce rayon on a vu que c'est 3 km
donc c'est très petit par rapport aux
distances qui sont en jeu mais c'est
vraiment ce terme- làà qui fait la
correction relativiste et donc qui va
apporter cette différence cette anomalie
de 43 secondes d'arc par siècle bon
alors on a déjà effectué une grosse
partie du travail maintenant la deuxième
partie ça va être d'essayer de résoudre
cette équation pour trouver la forme de
U et donc déterminer la forme de
l'orbite alors ça c'est encore une fois
très complexe puisque c'est une équation
qui n'est pas linéaire en U on voit ici
qu'on a un terme en U carré l'équation
newtonienne sans ce terme elle est
beaucoup plus simple à résoudre on peut
la résoudre de façon exacte c'est
l'équation d'un oscillateur mais avec ce
terme en U Carr c'est plus complexe donc
ce qu'on va faire c'est postuler la
forme de la solution en particulier on
se souvient de la vidéo sur Kepler et on
sait que la solution est de la forme une
constante plus une/ deè constante fois
le cosinus de l'angle Phi ça c'est la
solution de Newton pour l'orbite de
Kepler et effectivement si vous injectez
ça dans U Prim prime + U et bien ça
donne une constante ça donne la
constante a et donc en égalisant ce a
avec ce gm/ h² on retrouve bien une
solution de l'équation en particulier
ici ce B c'est lorsqu'on le factorise
par a ce qu'on appelle l'excentricité de
l'orbite on avait vu ça dans la vidéo
sur les orbites de Kepler l'excentricité
c'est simplement la forme de l'ellipse
si elle est plus ou moins allongée donc
une excentricité de zé ça donne un
cercle et puis une excentricité
supérieure à zéro ça donne une
ellipse mais ça c'est la forme des
orbites de Newton nous on veut trouver
une solution de cette équation là avec
le terme correctif ici en
u²r donc on va postuler que notre
nouvelle solution notre solution à cette
équation là elle est de la forme de
Newton mais avec une petite perturbation
on va plus utiliser l'angle Phi mais une
fréquence fois l'angle phi et cette
fréquence ne vaut pas forcément 1
c'est-à-dire que la période de l'orbite
ne vaut pas forcément 2 pi alors
pourquoi on fait comme hypothèse cette
forme- làà pour la solution et bien
c'est parce qu'on sait qu'on veut
retrouver une orbite qui précèe au cours
du temps on veut trouver une orbite dont
le Périé donc dont la période ne vaut
pas exactement 2 pi une orbite qui
reboucle légèrement plus tard que après
un angle de 2 pi donc on va postuler ici
qu'on a une fréquence qui est différente
de 1 et en particulier cette fréquence
elle doit quand même être très proche de
1 puisque l' préciation est très faible
la solution Newton est quand même une
très bonne approximation donc on va
poser que é la fréquence c'est 1 +
O est un nombre très petit par rapport à
1 donc ici omω Phi ça donne Ph+
EP pH où Epsilon est très petit donc je
vais noter Epsilon très petit par
rapport à 1 et on sait pas d'ailleurs si
ce Epsilon est positif ou négatif donc
c'est en valeur absolue alors on va voir
que cette forme làà de la solution ne
nous permet pas en réalité de résoudre
cette équation mais commençons par ça
essayons de résoudre l'équation en
postulant simplement qu'on a une
préession comme ça et voyons ce que ça
nous donne alors déjà on va commencer
par expandre ce u en faisant
l'approximation que Epsilon est très
petit vous connaissez peut-être la for
formu d'addition des cosinus COS A + B
ça c'est une formule qui est valable
tout le temps c'est COS a COS B Mo sin a
sin
B donc ici cos phi + Epson Phi ça va
être cos phi COS EP Phi moin sin Phi sin
EP Phi or Epsilon Phi c'est quelque
chose de très petit donc son cosinus ça
vaut à peu près 1 et puis Epsilon Phi
encore c'est très petit sinus de X quand
X est très petit c'est à peu près x donc
là on peut simplement retirer le sinus
donc si je réécris ça u c'est à peu près
égal à a + AE cos phi moin AE
EP Phi sin phi et c'est ce terme là qui
apporte une précession à l'orbite
puisque ça c'est l'orbite classique bon
alors à partir de là on peut calculer la
dérivée u prime prime dérivons une
première fois u prime ça c'est une
constante la dérivée de cos phi ça va
donner moin sin
Phi ici on a pH FO sin Phi donc il faut
calculer la dérivée d'un produit la
dérivée de UV c'est u Prim V + UV prime
donc on a moin AE
Epsilon sin Phi quand on dérive le
premier Phi moin AE EP Phi alors je vais
effacer ça COS F en dérivant le sin phi
et puis dérivons une deuxième fois
u Prim prime c'est Mo AE cos phi en
dérivant sin Phi Mo AE EPSIL cos phi en
dérivant ce sin phi et encore une fois
on a un produit donc AE Epsilon cos phi
lorsqu'on dérive par rapport à phi et
plus AE epilon Phi sin Phi quand on
dérive cos phi qui donnein sin fi alors
ces deux termes sont les mêmes on peut
les combiner ça donne un
2 et voilà l'expression de U Prim prime
lorsqu'on fait l'approximation que
Epsilon est très petit alors maintenant
il nous faut u²r donc on va faire le
calcul u² c'est le carré de tout ça or
on voit ici que u²r va être multiplié
par RS qui est très petit donc tous les
termes dans u²r qui vont dépendre de
Epsilon on peut s'en affranchir puisque
Epsilon est très petit RS le rayon de de
charield est très petit également et
donc leur produit c'est quelque chose
d'ordre 2 qu'on peut négliger donc
lorsqu'on fait le carré de tout ça on va
avoir ça au carré plus ça au carré plus
ça au carré mais on a un Epsilon carré
donc ça compte pas donc déjà
a² plus a² e² COS caré Phi plus les
termes croisés donc 2 fois ça et ça donc
+ 2 a² e cos phi plus tous les termes
qu' faut intervenir ça mais on a un
Epsilon donc on ne les prend pas en
compte alors voyez ici qu'on a un COS
carré et en fait c'est ça qui va nous
empêcher de résoudre l'équation avec
cette hypothèse là c'est que ce COS
carré vous connaissez aussi peut-être
cette formule de trigonométrie COS carré
d'un angle c'est 1 + COS de de fois cet
angle sur 2 donc je peux remplacer ici
COS caré Phi ça va me donner 1/2i plus
la même chose fois COS de 2
fi et ce COS de 2 fi là il est vraiment
différent de tous les autres termes qui
sont inclus et donc on voit que si on
veut égaliser tout ça avec une constante
on va pas y arriver on va pas réussir à
supprimer ce COS de de Phi sauf si la
constante a ou la constante e Val é0
mais on sait que dans notre cas ces deux
constantes ne peuvent pas valoir Z0 si a
vaut 0 alors notre orbite c'est
simplement un point situé au niveau du
soleil et si l'excentricit
alors on peut pas déterminer l'avance du
Pé puisque dans un cercle on n pas de P
en particulier on sa que l'excentricité
de mercure n'est pas nul
peu près
02 peut pas négliger TER il va falloir
trouver une façon de le supprimer pour
supprimer TER bien on peut simplement
postuler que dans notre solution il
existe un autre terme sous la forme de C
de de ajoutons un deuxè terme B x COS 2
Phi donc ça on le suppose simplement et
ce terme comme c'est une correction euh
par rapport à la version newtonienne et
ben on sait qu'il doit être aussi très
petit donc on peut rajouter Epsilon en
facteur en posant que la constante qui
intervient ici c'est une constante grand
B x Epsilon qui est très petit puisque
tout ça doit valoir 0 dans le cadre
newtonien alors si j'ai ce B EP COS de 2
fi lorsqu'on le dérive deux fois COS de
2 fi ça va donner - 4 on a ce 2 au carré
x COS de de fi donc ici dans U prime
prime je vais avoir - 4B Epil COS de 2
fi et encore une fois dans u²ré ça ne
change rien puisque ce terme dépend de
Epsilon donc on ne le prend pas en
compte et là c'est intéressant puisqu'on
a des termes ici qui vont permettre
potentiellement d'annuler ce terme-l et
de trouver une solution de cette
équation bon alors il nous reste plus
qu'à injecter ces trois expressions
là-dedans on recopie u prime
prime plus
U ça c'est ces deux termes 3/2 de RS
u²r et tout ça doit valoir GM sur h²
c'est-à-dire
une
constante bon alors ça paraît un peu
fastidieux comme ça mais en réalité on
voit qu'on a différents groupes de
termes on peut identifier qu'on a
d'abord toutes les constantes donc ça
c'est une constante ça c'est une
constante ça c'est aussi une constante
ça c'est aussi une constante donc ces
quatre constantes elles doivent être
égales si on veut trouver une solution
de l'équation donc on a une première
équation qui nous dit que A - 32 de RS
a²
3/4 de Rs a² e² doit valoir GM sur h² ça
c'est une première équation et puis on a
des termes en cause Phi celui-ci
celui-ci celui-ci et puis celui-ci et
ces termes doivent valoir zéro puisque à
droite on a aucun terme en COS de Phi
alors on voit en particulier que
celui-là s'annule déjà avec ça et en
fait ça c'est parce que notre solution
approximée si on prend que ça et ben
c'est déjà une solution du problème de
Newton mais par contre ces deux termesl
ne valent pas forcément ZrO mais on sait
que leur somme doit valoir zéro pour
être une solution donc on a une deuxième
équation c'est que 2A e Epsilon cos phi
+ 3 RS a² e cos phi doit valoir 0 et là
on peut diviser par cos
phi on peut diviser par
a et on peut diviser par
E et ça nous donne directement la valeur
de Epsilon Epsilon c'est - 3/2 de Rs X
a alors pour finir il faut vérifier que
tous les autres termes s'annulent eux
aussi donc ce terme-là en Phi sin phi et
celui-là et bien il s'annule bien on a
AE Epil AE Epil donc ça c'est bon et
puis on a ces termes-là qui nous ont
posé problème tout à l'heure en cause de
2 fi mais on voit ici que la constante B
n'est pas fixée c'est une constante
arbitraire et donc en choisissant la
bonne valeur pour B on peut réussir à
annuler ce terme-là donc en choisissant
la bonne valeur de B et en fait cette
valeur elle nous intéresse pas tant que
ça et bien on peut supprimer ces
termeslà donc on a réussi cette fonction
ici à l'ordre 1 en Epsilon c'est bien
une solution de notre problème des
orbites relativistes et en particulier
ce qui nous intéressait c'était l'angle
après lequel l'orbite a effectué un tour
complet et après lequel l'orbite revient
à son périelli cet angle il dépend de la
fréquence de l'orbite et donc il dépend
de ce petit Epsilon ici qui est vraiment
le paramètre de préession du périéie
donc ici la valeur de Epsilon c'est
vraiment ça qui nous intéresse et on
voit qu'elle dépend de la valeur de
grand A qu'on n pas encore déterminé
alors pour déterminer grand A on a C
première équation qui est un peu
compliqué mais on voit que grand A est
multiplié par RS qui est quelque chose
de très petit c'est le rayon de Shart
shield et donc grand en fait on veut
seulement sa première approximation on n
pas besoin de prendre en compte les
petites corrections relativistes dans la
valeur de grand a donc ici tout ce qui
dépend de Rs on peut le supprimer c'est
des corrections relativistes qui sont
très petites et on obtient que grand A
vaut à peu près GM sur H car et donc
voilà la formule qui nous donne la
valeur de Epsilon Epsilon c'est à peu
près - 3/2 de Rs x gm/
h² alors RS on le connaît c'est 2 GM sur
c² et donc ceci vaut à peu près - 3 g²
m² sur h² c² et ça c'est la valeur de
Epsilon on a encore une constante ici à
déterminer c'est ce grand H le moment
cinétique de l'orbite et en fait ce
grand H on peut le déterminer en
fonction des paramètres de l'orbite de
Mercure pour faire ça on peut revenir à
l'approximation newtonienne on voit ici
qu'on a u qui vaut a facteur 1 + E cos
phi et donc lorsqu'on inverse pour
obtenir r r C'est 1/ a sur 1 + E cos
phi donc a ici c'est la valeur qu'on a
déterminé GM sur h² donc 1/ a c'est h²
sur
GM ça c'est l'altitude de la planète par
rapport à l'angle Phi dans
l'approximation newtonienne donc on peut
déterminer par exemple quelle est
l'altitude minimale quel est le périéli
l'altitude minimale r- c'est lorsque le
dénominateur est maximal et donc c'est
lorsque cos phi est maximal c'est-à-dire
lorsque cos phi vaut 1 donc cette
altitude minimale c'est h²/ GM sur 1 + E
avec un raisonnement similaire
l'altitude max ma lorsque mercure est au
plus loin la Félie c'est h² sur GM sur 1
Mo e lorsque COS fi vaut 1 et avec ces
deux termes on peut déterminer ce qu'on
appelle le demi-gr axe donc lorsqu'on a
une orbite elliptique le soleil est ici
ça c'est
R+ la Félie ça c'est r- le périélie et
le grand axe c'est toute cette longueur
là donc en fait c'est r-+ R+ et le demi-
grandr axe en quelque sorte c'est la
moyenne entre R+ et r- donc c'est ça sur
2 donc ça c'est le demi-g axe qu'on note
généralement petit a et à partir de là
on peut déterminer ce demi-gr axe a
c'est simplement ça plus ça sur 2 donc
je peux factoriser c'est h²/ 2
GM facteur de 1/ 1 +
E + 1/ 1- e alors là en mettant les de
au même dénominateur j'obtiens h²/ 2
GM sur 1 + E x 1 - e ça donne 1 - e²
c'est l'identité remarquable A + B X a -
B et au numérateur j'obtiens 1 - E + 1 +
E ce qui donne 2 et donc finalement le
demi-gr axe vaut h²/ GM sur 1 -
e² autrement dit h²
vaut GM
a facteur de 1- e Carr et ça c'est super
puisque on a déterminé le moment
cinétique qui est une variable un peu
abstraite par rapport à quelque chose
qu'on peut observer en astronomie c'est
le demi- grand axe de l'orbite de
Mercure donc remplaçons ça dans Epsilon
on obtient - 3 g² m² sur h² c² donc sur
GMA 1- e²
c² et on peut diviser par GM en haut et
en bas on obtient enfin - 3
GM sur C car à 1- e car cette expression
c'est vraiment l'expression fondamentale
elle nous donne la valeur de la
précession du périélite de
mercure et alors pour finir nous ce
qu'on veut c'est savoir quel est l'angle
entre un Périé et le suivant après une
orbite donc on sait qu'on a quelque
chose de de la forme cosinus de Phi +
Epsilon phi et on veut savoir quand
est-ce que ça ça vaut 2 pi c'est-à-dire
quand est-ce qu'on a complété une
période de notre orbite alors pour que
ça Vale 2 pi Phi facteur de 1 + Epsilon
doit valoir 2 pi donc Phi doit valoir 2
pi divis par 1 + Epsilon c'est-à-dire à
l'ordre 1 facteur de 1 - Epsilon puisque
1/ 1 + EPSIL c'est à peu près 1- Epsilon
à l'ordre 1 et donc Phi doit valoir 2 pi
ça c'est dans le cas où ça boucle
parfaitement après un angle de 2 pi moin
2 pi x Epsilon et ça qu'on va noter
Delta Phi c'est l'avance du Périé
mercure donc voilà l'angle qui nous
intéresse alors on va le calculer c'est
donc 2 pi x
Epsilon Delta Phi = 2 pi x Epsilon ça
vaut donc et bien les moins s'annulent
et on voit qu'on a effectivement une
avance cet angle est positif 6 pi
GM sur c² a 1 -
e² alors ça c'est l'angle après une
orbite mais nous ce qui nous intéresse
c'est de savoir de combien le périélice
est décalé après un siècle et pour faire
ça et bien on va simplement diviser
Delta Phi par le temps que met la
planète à parcourir une orbite et puis
on va multiplier ça par un
siècle pour déterminer de combien le
périée s'avance après un siècle alors on
peut faire l'application numérique
ensemble ceci ça vaut donc Delta Phi
c'est 6 pi GM g c'est à peu près 6,7 x
10 - 11 en unité de système
international fois M c'est la masse du
Soleil attention pas de mer mercure donc
c'est 2 x 10^ 30 kg à peu près sur C car
donc c'est la vitesse de la lumière au
carré donc c'est à peu près 9 x 10^ 16 m
car par seconde carré FO a qui est le
demi- grandr axe de l'orbite de Mercure
alors là il faut le connaître c'est à
peu près 58 millions de kilmètr
c'est-à-dire 58 milliards de mètres fois
1 moin l'excentricité au carré et
l'excentricité de l'orbite de Mercure
c'est à peu près 0,2 donc au carré
0,04 et donc ça on veut le diviser par
la période
orbitale alors puisqueici on a un temps
divisé par un temps on peut choisir des
unités différentes que pour tout le
reste ici pour que ce soit plus pratique
on va choisir des jours et des jours la
période orbitale de mercure on peut
trouver en ligne que ça fait à peu près
jours et un siècle ça fait à peu près
365 jours x 100 100 x 10^ 2 puisqu'on a
100 années dans un siècle et voilà si on
effectue ce calcul on devrait en théorie
retrouver 43 secondes d'arc par siècle
mais attention il reste une dernière
conversion à faire ici c'est un angle en
radian et donc on veut convertir en
seconde d'arc c'est-à-dire en 3600 de
degr donc il faut faire fr
3600 et puis il faut multiplier par 360/
2 pi puisqu'on veut convertir des
radians 2 pi radian en
360° bon alors là je vous laisse faire
le calcul vous-même avec une calculette
et vous allez retrouver 43 secondes
d'arc par
siècle donc c'est assez bluffant de
refaire ce calcul par soi-même on est en
train vraiment de faire un calcul
historique qui a permis pour la première
fois de démontrer la supériorité de la
théorie d'Einstein par rapport à celle
de Newton en tout cas en ce qui concerne
le mouvement des planètes